it's gonna go
a7s
[Music]
there were two jordans in the studio
nobody knew
what to do
so we brought him on the podcast to see
who should
be called jordan
it was beautiful thanks is that
pre-written no
that's welcome to the corner
it looks like you're on your phone it's
kind of funny it looks like you're just
like sitting here texting but you're
making money
guys we've got a situation okay you may
have noticed there's a new person on the
podcast today his name's nick laurent
sorry i mean
it's easy to confuse us yeah it's me
we're very sorry i was gonna say it was
you jake you're in town
freshly shaved it too yeah okay so
i did shave
should i tell the reason why i shaved
it's not that's a little story it's a
little story it was one of those like
your your clippers ran out of battery
halfway so kind of that's yeah wait for
real well it was it was four a.m
i woke up
well to go to the airport oh monday
morning yeah and when i shave i like to
get up at four to do it yeah
i understand i get it yeah pre-430 type
shavers out there um so i was
in my bathroom and i'm like and i
pulled up the clippers and then i
realized that my youngest daughter was
asleep in the bed and i couldn't clip
because we were about to leave and that
would have woke her up
and then because yeah you can't clip
when someone's asleep right you can't
especially when she's only she's only 11
months old don't you dare clip so that
would have been
you know
so i didn't click inconsiderate then i
got on the plane and i'm looking haggard
as
haggard is all hell jake didn't clip
guys
right and so then you know despite the
fact that last podcast was sponsored by
manscaped i thought that's where this is
um is this one sponsored yes okay well
storyblocks has got you today but
you know i'm sure there's some stock
footage of someone shaving there's some
stock footage to someone shaving we'll
use that in the integration but anyways
just check back yeah check back in like
10 minutes um
so i didn't clip i get to the airport i
get on the plane i come here i show up i
and i'm like dude i can't show up like
this like because i don't grow facial
hair right here i i don't either yeah so
it comes in i get hairs yeah in single
hairs exactly and then you have like
like joshua tree on my face exactly
thank you yes a man who understands me
yeah so then i have these janky little
hairs dangling and it's not like i can
just pull it off as a beard
so then i so then i got it i went to big
bear market i got a throwaway razor i
shaved my cheeks but then i realized
that i had just shaved my cheeks and now
i had clean shaven cheeks with a full
goatee
and what you've done before i have done
that before but clean shaving cheeks
with a full goatee is just not really my
style anymore
so i switched it up and i was like well
i'm just gonna shave totally and now i'm
probably for the first time on the
podcast ever i'm appearing fully shaved
it's been years man
i'm honored to be here with you
cleanly shaving thanks and that's a
great transition jordan allen yeah
because jordan allen is here and uh the
man of two first names yes and you've
just joined us
from far and yonder
um so
now you're i'm here now you're here i'm
here on the couch i guess we can say
that like jordan is officially a
full-time corridor member
that's wild to hear nice
it's good to hear but it's wild to hear
dude you beat out 500 applications
that's even weirder that is something
that still hasn't made sense to me in
any way shape or form and it was but i'm
humbled to say the least we knocked it
down to like the top 30 and all of the
top 30 were like incredibly good and i
was just like i like yeah it was not
easy we we did many many and i had a
couple like friends who i'm friends with
in real life who are who had applied and
had made it up there and i was like
i don't know how to handle this
situation it's kind of awkward it's not
like a traditional job if you can even
call it a job it's it's what you because
we're not only looking for somebody
that's
good at visual effects and filmmaking in
general
but also somebody that can can do that
on camera yeah and play smash and play
replacement very important that was more
important
yeah grandfathered in i would never have
gotten
if you left him you tried to come back
there's no room dude you can't i need to
get a switch for sure yeah i wonder how
christian feels having another king k
rool main in the house oh yes that's
right i'm coming for that throne
christian's shaking his head
good you should be but i respect that
so so yeah you have like 500 enemies now
i do i know i want to meet them all come
on bye
bring your stream don't come by don't do
that
what was that process like i'm curious
because obviously on my end it was like
submit and then long period of silence
yeah and then continue the process yeah
and i know all of those who
that long period of silence has
continued
it's i can't send out like 500 emails
being like
you know 500 rejection emails it's just
isn't there like still don't you at
least feel any sort of like moral
obligation to at least notify them like
hey thanks for doing this
i guess yeah hey everyone who applied
thank you for applying um i'm sorry you
didn't make it in uh it wasn't an easy
call uh you have lots of great qualities
that we would love to see here in the
future maybe next time some more easy
calls and some of them have qualities
that we don't wish were here in the
future but
that's not to be said that there was
enough love a huge amount
of exactly the type of thing that
friend's talking about yeah
so if you didn't format your email
correctly no here here no here all the
rick rollers okay
the people who send me the emails trying
to rick roll me not realizing that
google automatically displays youtube
thumbnails in the email body those are
the people that i'm talking about
that's amazing
yeah yeah so they didn't use like a
bitly to hide the link no i mean come on
exactly sloppy works
come on
i'm gonna email jake a rickroll dude
he's gonna see it he's gonna talk about
it on the podcast and i'm gonna chuckle
i know there's one somebody out there
who's laughing at that right nothing's
cooler than using a meme that congress
used seven years ago oh you just killed
it right there
you did kill it good job
all right sorry ran that was a very rude
interruption on my part i apologize
no i'm just saying it's like i it's so
hard because there's so many people who
watch what we do and would love to work
with us
and uh there it's the there's a huge
variety of those kinds of people and
the simple truth is that i guess you
know obviously not everyone can make it
and i guess you're saying that you can't
even respond to all of them that they
didn't make it
yeah even if it was just like a copy
paste like hey sorry
what i mean is that what would that be
the right call this is an interesting i
didn't know that let us know in the
comments you know if you applied and you
didn't hear back and i'm sure you've
been kind of like annoyed and frustrated
that you haven't heard maybe you know
okay so you know what maybe this is
where it's coming from
i don't feel an obligation to respond
back because i remember in 2008 when i
graduated from college it was the height
of the recession and i was like i'm
going to get a job i'm going to get a
job today that's what i'm going to do
and i went out and i took my little
stupid resume
and that wasn't stupid i worked very
hard at that resume but it
you know it's dinky it's like yo here's
my little resume right here here it is
i'm going to put it out into the world
and um i submitted that resume
to
i think over 400 positions
wow that is a lot i have never applied
to anywhere close to that many places
ever that's his flag right there i
submitted my resume to over 400
400 submissions and these weren't like
hey come be a full-time vfx artist
camera personality and editor and
creator at cordon digital this was like
account manager for multi-tier
management firm that's selling telecom
to you know business to business
like whatever like you know fun jobs
like way more exciting like you know
very corporate fortune 500 like we just
need warm bodies to do this stuff and
yes you can work your way up the ladder
but like this is where you start kid
400 over 400 and i think i got maybe one
response back
so that's when i learned i was just like
oh well people just don't respond
like if you don't get the j if you don't
you know if you didn't get it because
you didn't hear back
i mean i'll be honest with you jake i i
can't blame you for not responding
because i'm awful at responding to
emails like especially if there are
rejections i'm not trying to be a jerk
if this is like something that's totally
outside the reasonable bounds of
civilized society then i'll respond i
just didn't assume that it was like
something that i just people would
people would think as like i i deserve a
response like maybe they do i don't i
don't know honestly i don't know i mean
i
i i don't have much experience trying to
apply to different companies
honestly corridor was kind of the first
big job i got out of college
it's a good start
but uh i always kind of imagined that
usually there's a courtesy email being
like hey thank you for applying
there is when you apply to college
usually okay
you have to pay for that application you
have to pay for that application yeah
and all they do is send you a small form
letter
with your name on it yeah i mean i
second that i've applied to a lot of
like positions on film sets and whatnot
and you usually don't hear anything back
you just assume like oh i haven't heard
back
let's just keep sending them out yeah i
guess i'm i'm also just kind of
remembering a lot of the um
a lot of the stuff i heard the last time
i went through a hiring phase there was
a lot of people who were like upset that
they didn't get the job and were very
vocal about that
abraham lincoln once said
you can keep most of the people happy
most the time but you can't keep all the
people happy all the time and then he
swung an axe and killed a vampire that's
right yep and that vampire was the
confederacy
it's beautiful
and that was the last day racism existed
that's right i will say that when i
didn't hear back i immediately assumed i
didn't get it
i mean honestly the minute i hit send i
assumed i didn't get it were you upset
no i did it so that when i was old i
wouldn't say what if right that's
literally the only reason i i found like
a saturday to put together the reel and
yeah and actually make a go of it and i
just did it purely to silence the voice
in my head that is always wondering what
if
you know so i noticed that that you
waited
to tell the week so there's some people
we put out the call and then people
email right away yeah and
usually none of those people make it
through because it's already something
that they have
like ready to go
so it's like same day you know within 24
hours but then like the following
weekend and the following weekend after
that is when we get like the batch of
people that are like oh these are the
people that actually put time into this
yeah like these are these are the ones
we've been waiting for and so that
usually those ones is where we get the
30 40 people that those aren't the ones
that just procrastinated until the last
minute like oh crap that's right my
dream job i got to apply i did kind of
procrastinate to be honest
yeah it was between like have a sandwich
or finally do the video yeah and i was
like you know what equal importance yeah
i am wondering what if about that
sandwich because
you know i don't think i can get away
from that
just picking the petals off of sunflower
like okay apply knot but i think
i figured i thought you know if i if i
re-cut my reel to be a little more
centered towards what you guys were
looking for and what you you listed in
your video yeah then at least at the end
of it i'll have something yeah that is a
little that stood out to me because you
you added these like little transitions
of you like dancing and stuff i don't
know
was that for a project or did you do
that for the real so there was a an open
house at some green screen studio in la
and we were me and my friend brandon toy
were hired to basically do like live
green screen demonstrations oh and it
slowly started to form into what we
called dj liquid which is this dance
video of the two of us
and yeah it's excerpts from that so i
got i get the dj liquid yes it's like
yeah
uh and then i also noticed that in your
reel not only did you have work that you
had done
that was you know high quality
work but also you had work that you had
done where you
were in it
which which goes to me it goes okay this
person knows how to act or create their
own content as well as do content with
others for others etc right so that's
kind of the
that's kind of the essential
raw ingredients yeah that you need and
so yeah usually what i'll do is i'll
flip through and i'll have like my
bullet point of raw materials that i'm
looking for like you know
depending on what type of asset it is or
what type of position it is and then
you know i'll say okay this person this
person has those things and as soon as i
see that they had they meet those like
raw materials like they could do this
this this and this i'll just immediately
take the email and throw it into another
category which is just round two i just
go okay
i'm not gonna look at it any further
right now i just know that that person
and it's very loose it's kind of like
bingo it's very loose
it's not bingo it's it's not like random
it's like i'm i'm looking for you're
looking like a sniper you're looking for
a particular
that's a cooler yeah yeah
yeah i mean it's not like
bingo is game yeah bingo implies chance
yeah which of course there's a lot of
when you apply to well every yeah
there's an amount of luck and change i
think it's actually totally fine
there's no snipers here this is big yeah
okay it's a sniper playing bingo okay
come on
uh really old sniper that is something
that i i'm
i'm now wondering because when when it
came time to actually looking at some of
these final uh these finalists um
on-screen charisma was one of the things
we're looking at but that wasn't a
requirement on the application well no
because
you might get somebody who's just the
best freaking vfx artist ever
and they may be terrible on camera is
that person still super valuable to what
we do here yeah hell yeah yeah
absolutely so i wouldn't want to
like tell people no you have to be on
camera like if somebody's extremely
talented at their job
and they don't want to be on camera
that's fine yeah you know i will say
that we were kind of looking for someone
on camera like prioritizing that more
because i feel like we've been a little
bit short-staffed around here
in terms of at least i feel that way
yeah who we have who can on screen do
vfx and
talk about vfx yeah i mean no don't get
me wrong like
when we put out that out we were kind of
looking for two people to be honest we
were looking for one person who could be
on camera and one person who could
just do effects
and
if that person is also good on camera
then
bonus
right but we weren't hiring an actor
not hiring an actor here right yeah so
that's not like the primary function
remember how bad we were go look at the
2016 no please don't it's okay no
seriously watch the whole season
it's it's it's
it's terrible
is that your mustache son
i don't know what you're talking about
you know the even funnier ones
go back prior to 2015 and watch those
ones
and it's like it's uh just we're all so
awkward we don't know what to do on
camera like yeah i mean it's it's it's i
know exactly we're talking about because
being on camera is an acquired skill
at least for me i don't think i had any
innate talent for being on camera most
of
my
whatever you call it on camera that uh
people like is definitely oh i like that
yeah
it's called moxie uh
i don't know what that means anyway
that's what you're describing oh great
cool i i know now
that was all pretty much uh cultivated
over the course of years of just slowly
gaining more experience of like doing
something on camera seeing how it looked
in the edit and seeing people's
responses on youtube and then like
i don't know for me that kind of came
down to just encouraging more of my
inner self to come out right um
so
yeah in the early days of me being on
camera especially if you like go to like
my channel and look at some of my
earlier videos like circa 2010 2011.
like this fish fish
dude
i actually know that one fish is a
better actor than you back then yeah
sorry
i'm done
red
rip
[Music]
how close this was dude
my point is that if you hadn't been good
on camera
i wouldn't i we would have still you
would have still made it through the
first round probably through the second
round
like maybe even to the third you know
because like i still wanted to see based
on the work that you'd right you had
done
the thing
nico had pointed out because he was the
one who kind of identified you earlier
than the rest of us
uh was that you had done some things in
your reel that made you stand out
wasn't it wasn't specifically that you
were on camera for any of that because
there are lots of artists who uh made it
into those final rounds who only used
blender they were only blender artists
they only did full cg stuff
um but you had demonstrated that you
knew how to basically take an idea from
like
or to take a concept from just the idea
to the final product including shooting
photography for it doing all the effects
and rendering for it and then
compositing and then kind of wrapping it
all up into a package
that is the final thing because
interesting okay in the effects world a
lot of people you know especially in the
industry they do one thing and they
don't handle anything before or after
that thing
and so you know they might not have as
much experience with shooting something
or planning the blocking of a shoot or
doing sound design and i think when we
started out this job application we
weren't really thinking about that but
when we saw it and you are real it was
kind of like okay
okay
that's cool to hear them the dancing and
work and then the dancing skills yeah
the dancing would have gotten me to the
third round
by itself and granted there were a lot
of people who had very similar
applications to yours
um no no i guess you're right he's gonna
set you apart apparently
no i mean i'm trying to acknowledge that
there were other people who also
demonstrated those qualities right um
who were again excellent yeah
and yeah it's always uh
at the end of the day you know your
restrictions are
a couple things like one obviously you
know what your financial bandwidth is
like how how many people can we afford
to hire that's obviously the the first
one the second one is
which who of these people
have strengths
that either we need to add to
in within where we're already at or have
strengths that are complementary
to other people that are already here
because you know you're you're trying to
create
sam and i
always talk about this
it's like
you know it's a garden man it's a it's
an ecosystem it's an environment and you
want to make sure that it's
got
its little
you know
roots
all over
so that way not any one thing can
blow you over you know and that's like
when you're when you especially in a
creative in industry um because stuff
does change
and platforms change and
the times change and you have to be able
to
i miss the old corridor i miss when you
guys did this type of content yeah thank
you for staying here man yeah i missed
the 2015 vlogs
you can watch all of them
and it's like you can spend like three
days
inside of that world
there's been a theme
throughout the entirety of my career
here at corridor of like i miss what you
used to do lately the last year or two
it's like all you guys ever do anymore
is just vfx startups react it's getting
stale it's the only thing you make
anymore i missed when you made vlogs and
it's like i totally get that sentiment
first off a
screw you oh
no i agree though because it's not
that's literally like less than half the
videos yeah like we
most of our effort goes into all of the
crew videos that come out every sunday
every single week uh we've got a pretty
good pipeline for the vfx stars react i
still think they're excellent um
but it's not the main focus for most of
us here at the company and secondly we
were getting those comments two years
ago when we started uh whatever we were
doing two three years ago they're like
oh man i miss when you get just had a
quarter video and a behind the scenes
and that was it
all you guys do these days are just
vlogs no one likes those vlogs guys you
should really go back to doing what you
got successful doing in the first place
it's like whoa okay
and it's like you see that and you kind
of you can't help but kind of think
about it for a moment and then be like
this is the same argument i've heard
every year for the last 10 years
[Music]
guys i've been trying to learn a new
finger picking technique you know it
reminded me of today's sponsor story
blocks when you're trying to learn a new
finger picking technique you know you
have to retrain your brain and the
reason why that reminded me of story
blocks is because instead of going out
and filming your own b-roll and
capturing all of the audio assets that
you're gonna need for a video you just
need to get in the habit of using
storyblocks they're the one-stop shop
for all your stock asset needs for
creators and businesses alike they have
high quality 4k b-roll audio after
effects templates motion graphics and
more remember they have a virtually
unlimited library they're updating it
all the time we use the unlimited all
access plan which allows us to download
as much as we want whenever we want and
use it royalty free however we want if
you're not in the habit of utilizing a
stock footage platform get in the habit
of it because if you're not you're
wasting time you're going to learn how
to make videos incorrectly just like you
would do if you were not utilizing the
proper techniques to learn fingerpicking
so obviously i have a lot of work to do
on this song because i don't even know
if that came out like anything coherent
and in the meantime you guys should head
over to storyblocks.comcast
to get started over there
storyblocks.com or cast i got a lot of
learning to do and uh probably you do
too so let's get after it
[Music]
everyone's gonna like different things
and i i share the sentiment like you
can't help but get salty when we
literally bust our butts every week to
make i've been busting my butts and
grinding my biscuits and burning my
gears well not only does it
i i i think this vfx artist react like i
i want to call it hate but you know
distaste not only i think
disses on all the hard work that goes
into that show which is a ton especially
in editing yeah it is not a low effort
type of video no at all it takes a week
or more to edit one of those things
right between one or two people yeah no
i mean it's like
it's it's not react it's actually an
educational show where we're teaching
these concepts to people who would never
be able to learn about them
or at least in all the illustrations
people never really recognize
the illustrations that they see that uh
you dean or chase you know they create
for this show
and
that you see it in the context of the
show and you just you your brain absorbs
it before you even acknowledge that you
just saw something that someone probably
spent an hour or two creating just to
help drive home some random thing i said
to make sense better yeah
dean and chase
they bust their butts man yeah
i don't think people really
grasp
how good
those guys are
like like taking
hours of content and whittling it down
into something and how fast they are
yeah and like
it's
it's [ __ ] amazing when we sit down
and record a react show it's like it's
probably around two hours of filming
sitting there on the couch filming so
that's two camera feeds a
screen capture on the tv and three audio
feeds that all have to be synchronized
and then cut down to a 15 minute video
that you enjoy on your saturday mornings
yeah and coming up 30 minute videos for
the website but we'll get into that
later
i
because i agree like we've been seeing
these comments forever
and
half the videos we put out still
are
basically the same kind of videos we've
been doing since 2016. and also people
like they're like i missed when you
uploaded a video every other day it's
like you don't post nearly that much
anymore and but it's like if you
actually total up the watch time or
sorry the minutes of a video it's like
we used to put out videos every other
day that were three minutes long i think
this bothers ren more than it bothers me
because i think you're a naturally more
empathetic person than i'm yeah i'm
for sure
yeah i'm very empathetic i am not immune
to criticism
it's taking two and a half billion views
to kind of feel like i have somewhat
thick skin well yeah it's because you're
invested in it i mean i i get waves of
that too sometimes when i see those
comments yeah that's true it feels bad
for people to write off what we do now
and say you know
you're not as good and it's not
everyone's cup of tea which is fine like
some people
don't like the react and they just want
to see
us sit in a room and talk about tiny
guns brainstorming right
podcast yeah and that's fine like but
like there was a time for that
did that like yeah we lost oh there it
is nobody's here um there's a time for
that very sorry god
yo sorry sorry matt is turning off the
light he's trying to mess up
he's struggling is he testing us so
interesting yeah
you're turning off these lights
i don't know what's going on it's an
aperture switch it's
fun
yeah
sorry matt and i are going to be
shooting a pretty intense video tomorrow
morning about solar panels
so he's trying to get all the lights
going uh on the green screen
and uh aperture lights use these little
remotes
there they're there
so matt is out in the other room staring
at the green screen wondering why are my
lights not turning on meanwhile we're
going dobies in here
sorry dude you were the ghost the whole
time
are you living in my attic dude the the
secret identity of doby has been finally
revealed a real scooby-doo moment
um
but yeah nick yeah oh no i mean
all i'm saying is like
nostalgia is a real thing
and yeah yeah i
try to i try to remember exactly i try
to remember that when i read those
comments it's like people are nostalgic
for it
i think carmichael's videos definitely
had a quality that is different than
what we do now oh absolutely like we
made i think it was what like in 2018 we
made a decision we're like
we're gonna start doing single story
videos that are more
topical and easy to share basically
because it's like we would sit down and
we'd work
we'd bust our butts every week making
these videos that had like two or three
storylines
and
i remember i mean i've touched on this
before but like i tried to like share a
video with someone i'd be like yo check
out this fun video it's really
educational and i'd sit him down and
then it would be us
like with a [ __ ] fan in our in our
pants like blown
oh no no away that part like here you
just gotta skip to 3 13 and then skip to
6 16 and then skip to 8 to 18 and then
you'll learn what we're trying to get
down so it was like very scattered it
was very fun and casual but scattered to
like and and that's why i think we've
actually grown more i literally just
experienced that exact thing last week
on vacation with my niece okay she's
nine i think and she was uh watching a
old crew video titled
ren loses his mind over no internet or
something like that because we're doing
something with the wall remember when we
like had we're kicking out the the door
yeah and i hit you on the head with the
the drywall yeah um they were wanting to
watch that and so we gathered my whole
extended family to around this laptop to
watch this [ __ ]
and so my niece hits play and it's just
sam and nico sitting in the corner in
here bitching about something okay yeah
i thought it was gonna be like a blowjab
fan moment dude the condom gun the
condom gun battle that was a good video
dude and i'll never forgive carmichael
for that
dude no no i'm just i'm still a little
salty about it because he threw it at me
it hit my face split my lip open not
this split that i got going on right now
still split he never apologized for it
he was like oh
and walked away i was like that really
hurt dude like anyway
that entire video was just like michael
hurting me and being completely
unapologetic about it
were you shot in the lip with a condom
no he threw the the they had because
that's what's in my head
yeah i mean projectiles
it was like this rubber gun
and it had a little it has a little
plastic circle and then there's a rubber
part connected to it so it kind of looks
like a condom oh i see and then there's
a little project plastic projectile in
there and you shoot it they were
insanely powerful yeah yeah they're
scary but you can like kill squirrels
with them and stuff or split lips you
know he threw the entire thing at me
like he threw the condom at my face
and it just
like hit your mouth no it was it was the
plastic that you hold on to that's rigid
so that you can it's like it's a what do
you call it
yeah it's a slingshot and then
i'm still upset about it
i can't take that video down from the
internet it sucks
no no i'm just saying uh yeah you know
it's
they're they're yeah i totally get what
you're saying those split story lines i
thought were a really cool idea no one
else was really doing them which is why
we were doing them and they worked
for a lot
yeah they were to an extent um
it was good for a vlog
but the thing was is that it prevents it
prevents long-term growth
on the youtube platform because what you
want is like
you were saying you want to you want a
concise
story
that's paid off through the marketing
people click on they watch it they go
hey that story delivered everything i
was looking for and more and now i'm
interested to learn more about who this
creator is because maybe they have more
videos it's like the first time you hear
a song from a band that you've never
heard of and you're like wait do they
have any more
can you imagine if they like the next
song you heard wasn't in any way like
the first one no that's halfway through
the song suddenly the band is like so
this is our podcast yeah yeah and uh
right and you're like it would be
totally utterly confusing
what the hell is this
um
we realized at around that time that
better quality stories meant more
focused stories imagine like halfway
through the the video where i built a
a a 3d printed finger for jan we just
start randomly trying to do hoverboard
races
like that's the kind of content we used
to make
and i think as a result our content
elevated in quality significantly yeah
and there's a there's a creative
restriction and challenge in that
and that's why we we do what we do now
is because it's like
these these videos now you know some of
them are 20 plus minutes long
there's a whole
like strategy and
writing that has to go into it and
development that has to go into it it's
not just like
we just show up
so i just had a meet-up up in oregon
last friday
which was super cool by the way i was
like with one day's heads up in a random
city in the middle of
uh rural oregon i was like hey anyone
want to come meet up at this time and 10
people showed up it was pretty cool uh
shout out to all you guys but
um
they
one of the questions they brought up
that i found interesting is that they
often because i've seen this in comments
they thought that a lot of our content
was scripted
and
it's never scripted no it's like talking
points for a brand can sometimes be
scripted but it's usually more of an
improv style thing where you have like
some
some like inputs what do you what do you
call them i i forgot even then uh
the prompts right yeah it's like a
caricature it's like a low-level
caricature of real life yeah it's not
it's not
scripted
i i was just going to say the functional
filmmaking episode that i did
basically gives a pretty good window
into that
yeah and like yeah that's a more
scripted example
scripted like there were way more
prompts going on in that storyline than
a lot of our videos have even now
um
because yeah it's like you know uh
we'll plan a moment but we're not gonna
plan the specifics of that moment we're
just gonna let whatever happens we'll
let that play out and that's what we
capture sometimes it requires kind of
going back in and be like all right we
have everything that we captured edited
together it works as a story but we need
to get a couple different pickups to
kind of glue it together those will be a
little bit more specific but they still
won't be scripted
jordan i'm interested to hear on that
note
what were your expectations of like
seeing our final content versus what
it's like being part of it yeah did it
seem scripted to you versus not or does
it seem more scripted now that you're
here it i would say it's like you guys
seem more like [ __ ] yeah i didn't
want to say that though
um
i didn't have too much expectation going
in um
i wasn't really sure like to what extent
it was scripted and what it wasn't you
know um i was just kind of
anxious for the first moment where i saw
a camera and i actually expected it to
be a lot more frequent up in the office
than what it would appear to be it's
like 95 of the time it's complete
silence up there which i'm okay with but
i remember i think it was like my third
day here when i was here for a week a
couple weeks back
and uh i think it was your camera i saw
a light over my shoulder on the third
day and i thought oh that glow it's that
moment i've been thinking about here we
go
yeah i prepared my script in advance and
no it's it's uh
it's not it's not yeah it's kind of to
your point it's like you find yourself
in a situation where like daniel in the
weekly videos you know will give me
something to look at and we'll just film
me
looking at it
and i never know his intention right
none of them so yeah i'm always like
what's going on
you know um but uh but yeah it's it's
kind of you you capture what you capture
and i like it that way personally i like
it that way a lot because i sorry to
butt in but it's like daniel's vlogs uh
on the website are incredible yeah
i they are kind of more scripted in the
loose term of scripted than anything
else we produce because daniel has a
very specific idea of what the story
should be as he's
editing it as he's recording it and he
will try to shoot for his imaginary edit
that's in his head and so he'll ask you
a question
he'll ask me a question for instance and
i'll start like you know talking about
it and he's just politely nodding his
head and then i'll get to the end of it
all and realize he's not going to use
any of it because i didn't say what he
wanted me to say so then he'll ask kind
of the same question pose it a little
bit differently and i'll say it again
and he's like hmm is there any sort of
like like maybe you want to
do something like this and i'm like
oh right you want me to say this which
supports this other thing happening in
the video okay so i'm like all right
yeah so uh you know jordan's a great guy
i think he'll do great here that would
not be the one that is scripted that
should be completely organic instead of
talking about your taco lunch
is it more like you think that jake
really represents a perfect symbol of
leadership in the studio
and is an idol to stand by and always
yes
but like
when you watch the products though
they're so good and that's that's the
thing
sometimes about it in the moment i'm
like okay fine i'll say this thing you
want a lot of time i straight up will
refuse be like i don't i don't want to
say that i don't want to say it and so i
won't because i want to be honest with
myself and
but like let's say i like all right fine
i'll say the thing i'll say it
it it sounds natural and then i see in
the final thing i'm like oh my god
daniel you're a genius you're like i
didn't want to say that but i'm glad i
said it yeah yeah thank you for having
me say that
but yeah i feel like he's just trying to
rig up as many like
video versions of explosions as possible
and just like set them set one off and
see how many else go off at the same
time
and that's dude i love it because
speaking of the old day vlogs and all
that stuff it gives me a sense that
it still lives in the studio yeah
you guys aren't the only ones nostalgic
man all i mean we all probably go down
rabbit holes where we're watching
ourselves in the studio and it feels
like yesterday yeah i haven't done it in
a while but every now and then i'll like
i'll sit down and i'll just like i'll
watch like 10 videos from randomly from
the last
five years start hunting for b-roll and
i'll go down a rabbit hole and i'm like
oh yeah that moment happened oh yeah
remember that time and it'll just be
like dang like there's been a lot of
good times here yeah
[Laughter]
so you were here for a week we actually
had a few different artists here for a
week each
um and so the week you're here you and i
worked on clint's render challenge which
i think came out pretty good hey we made
top 100 we did we don't have to
kill our friendship with clint i was
prepared to do it
anyway uh that video uh how do you think
that came out versus
your experience of being in the video
like like you're here through that whole
week oh i know what happened behind the
scenes of a lot of that stuff
and
then you sit down and you watch the
final video
what are your thoughts i i'm my own
worst critic
always i'm sure maybe that's true of all
of us but i kind of didn't want to watch
it i was like i should watch it what am
i doing like this is such a fun week so
i sat down and i watched it and i was
really pleasantly surprised okay good i
really was because it was such a fun
like
obviously you can't put the entire week
in the video and there were like so many
moments of me just internally stressing
over like oh i gotta get this thing to
work i gotta get this thing to work um
but even even with that involved it's
like i have such good memories of that
week and like meeting you all and like
the the absolute whirlwind that it was
for that week it was a whirlwind um you
know like sitting down in the in the
first meeting while i was here and and
being between sam and nico and just
being like what the heck is going on
and they're like looking back at me i'm
so used to looking at them on the screen
and having them look at me i'm like
sam's just not should i be trying to
work for you sam's just like you don't
know if he's mad at you
i don't mind um but i was obviously
thrilled to see it yeah okay i was i was
very proud of it i mean yeah i guess um
i i'm just i don't know i find myself
curious how that that that appears to
people not familiar with the process
because i'm
i wouldn't say i'm jaded to it but i'm
so used to the whole process that it's
i'm
i'm not an unbiased viewer anymore yeah
and
because like you're saying 95 of the
time it's just quiet up there it didn't
used to be quiet when we were down here
there was always stuff going on
it was still not being filmed 95 of the
time but it was at least
not quiet
well i feel like it's an inverse curve
it's like the less people that were
working here
the more goofing off you could do
because the less money you'd waste by
doing that
but as we start to hire people it's like
now we're wasting all this money and
then get to work
no but like really it
i don't know if there was a 2016 to 2018
was like
the years of just filming every single
thing going on in the studio because
there always was
something wacky going on there were like
just enough people to make that work i
think well that was back when like the
content that we made was specifically
what are we doing today we always try to
make it not like this is what i'm having
for lunch that was like the classic vlog
at the time which we wanted to not do
but there it it still came down to like
what are we doing today we're gonna
document it and it was just that every
single day and um you know a lot of the
time what we're doing that day was
working on a new corridor film and so
there's a lot of behind the scenes for
that and
that evolved into
reviewing electric skateboards and
having hoverboard versus one wheel races
yeah uh that was totally rigged by the
way um
not actually rigged i'm just saying it
was unfair um well some would say unfair
some would say fair and square
uh but as we started you know maturing
in in making the kind of content that we
did
we realized that it wasn't very high
quality content in terms of storytelling
uh it could there's there's certain
elements of that that we've tried to
maintain and i think we've done a decent
job of maintaining that but like
you know sometimes you need a little bit
of planning and there's a reason why
editing happens
it's because
you cut out all the boring things in
between plot points and when you just
record everything in between and then
and then look for a plot point you're
doing it backwards that's what it was
yeah we would film something and then
try to look for the story right
oh that sounds like a disaster yeah that
was that was 2016 to 2018. that was that
exact format dude you'd be surprised how
many documentary filmmakers do that yeah
like they're just like oh yeah i'm a
hands-off documentarian i want it
exactly how it is and then they're
shooting themselves in the foot because
they get in the edit room they're like
ah okay i probably should go back and
film some voiceover for this right dang
all right let me
know
yeah i have no story hey you know what
i'm gonna film
i'm gonna i'm gonna get inside of a of a
of a wall street hedge fund okay and
then i'm going to
work my way up the chain and record
everything and then i'm going to do a
tell all in an amazing documentary
wouldn't you like to see that it's like
yeah i'd be interested in seeing that
okay so i did that and then i realized
that um
like the hedge fund guys like they feel
a vital niche in like the market and
they help like drive up prices when
they're going down and down when they're
going up and they help balance the
market and they're actually like really
good guys and like there's nothing very
special about it's just a lot of math
and um like a lot of sitting in front of
computers boring was that a real
conversation no but that's so specific
if you didn't if you didn't i was using
it as an example
if you didn't
tell a story if it wasn't like so i got
inside of the hedge fund and these guys
are snorting lines of coke and they're
messing with the markets and they're
manipulating everybody and everything
and every dollar that goes into the
market is actually manipulated and wrong
and it's actually going to dumping
plastic into the ocean and yeah maybe
you put some baking soda on their table
and you put it in a line who cares
it's the story
if i if it was version a
it would be like
okay i'm glad they're doing that i'm not
gonna watch your documentary
yeah there's no conflict there's no
story there's no drama there's no
overcoming a challenge there's no
yeah it's like there is value in that
style of capture you know just capturing
what's going on raw but david
attenborough narrating i mean yeah i
mean that's another thing dude
that stuff is incredibly like i i don't
know how to describe it scripted is
again i don't think the correct word
scripted oh it's super scripted i guess
yeah remember the guy we talked to at
nab exactly exactly where they like they
specifically go out and try to capture
like specific scenes and so a lot of the
time in planet earth you're watching
this story of this this one family of
animals meanwhile behind the scenes it's
like five different packs of animals
that you just can't tell the truth i did
not know that yeah
in macro shots they'll even film those
in controlled environments if they
really need to get in there with good
lighting and stuff yeah depends on the
show but often it's extremely scripted
they're like all right get the beetle
close up and so okay so let's get
specific about this because a lot of
times people hear that and they go i
shattered you just shattered
planet earth for me david attenborough's
a liar the bbc is a farce
okay but no david happened
he's behind it he's the guy
here's the thing is what they try to do
is for in that example is
they try to give you
like the most interesting
situation that could result
that does result from these animals
existing
that's what they're trying to do it's
like yeah did it had did all of this
happen to this particular lion family at
this particular time like with this
particular zebra no
but like now you understand what it's
like for a lion you understand why their
life's important you understand how they
contribute to the food chain you
understand where they live what their
environment is like why that's all it
needs to be
there yeah
before you didn't you just described
daniel yeah
yeah exactly because they'll do you know
capture a lot of that stuff and then
they'll maybe like fabricate a story
that makes the different pieces of
footage make sense together that's such
a revelation daniel is making a planet
earth show about our studio dude
oh he'll observe there's something
happening in the wild something in the
natural order he'll observe it he'll be
like that's a story and this is like oh
my god kind of the
it's the more advanced version of what
seemed like and i used to do yeah still
do because because he's still capturing
stuff for real it's still raw stuff that
he's capturing he's like i need i need
the shot of the hyena or of rand
printing you know pressing click on his
keyboard and i'm going to like light it
and i'm going to freaking get the best
shot and color grade the [ __ ] out of it
and it's going to be amazing but it's
all based on a real event yeah yeah
it's just a little bit staged
to like to be satisfying i don't even
think of that he's the bbc dude
yeah subscribe to quarterdigital.com so
you can also watch the bbc and he's in
daniel 4 still working right now
daniel's still working that is one thing
that i did notice
my first week here
was the thought you guys put into the
idea of like having conflict in a video
and resolution in a video and yeah
something that makes it a little more
engaging to watch than
just the pit or patter of keys
and then a render at the end you know
yeah yeah and that's what i i've also
found that that's exactly what makes it
difficult to take idea suggestions from
people it works for vfx artists react
all they have to do is say the title of
a movie maybe the scene of a movie but
when i've i have a lot of uh you know
random people or friends suggest like
ideas for videos be like oh i should do
this video about this thing and it's
like
i instantly am able to identify that
that's not gonna make for a good video
because of what you just said it doesn't
have the right type of conflict or
sort of like arc for a video and i'm
like
it's a cool kind of idea but i don't
think it works for a video is the most
requested one you get
make an r rated film rated g
because i get that all the time a lot
yeah and i'm like we suggested it
dude we suggested it to begin with we
weren't the first we did
no no no we weren't the first ones
we first started getting those comments
i believe on our first r-rated video
okay like what other things would you
like to see already they're like make an
r-rated film g and we're like and we
started to think about it well i said it
on camera i said what if we uh made an
r-rated movie rated g like what if we
made saw rated g was that in the first
one that was i think maybe in the second
one i don't think it was the first well
i could totally be wrong but i don't
remember i don't remember seeing it a
lot uh all of this is happening because
ren made a comment asking people dang it
but no i think you're right though i
think that's an obvious it's the same
reason why we still get comments being
like you should make an unsatisfying
render challenge because it's just like
a logical conclusion to make from the
videos we've done oh you've done this
you've done the yen let's do the yang it
makes sense
it's i
sometimes that doesn't work it's like
hey
you want to you want to go to you want
to go to a party and get drunk
or it's like hey
do you want to wake up hungover
it's like no no
you don't
you know maybe that's a bad analogy
maybe that's a terrible analogy but like
do you understand what i'm saying
like the unsatisfying render thing it's
like
it's like
hey could be do you want to drive do you
want to drive a car at 120 miles an hour
most people are like yeah yeah let's do
it and then it's like hey do you want to
flip in a car eight times
have your teeth bashed against the
windshield
well it's like no i don't want it it's
like well
it doesn't seem like what you're saying
is like it sounds like you're not
following my logic no one's following
i'm fine i'll be the first one to say i
don't i'm not following i don't think
what he's trying to try to follow i
think what he's trying to say is it
sounds great in the marketing but when
you actually start thinking about it
coming down to brass tacks
it doesn't really hold much water
because it's like okay we take deadpool
and we take out all the blood
then it's just unsatisfying action
cool i guess
that's probably not going to go viral i
mean
yeah and granted we could make a video
like that entertaining we could totally
do that
uh yeah
i guess my i i because again i do want
to make an unsatisfying render challenge
i think that'd be a lot of fun uh and i
think it'd be
you know people i are expecting
something like that so they would
probably watch it but at this i guess
i'm just using that as an example of
something people suggest most of the
time when people suggest oh you should
make a video about this it's like one
small thing when especially like my my
personal specials that i make are like
30 of those small things and they're
like you should make a whole video about
this one thing it's like
no
did just make a video about life on
planet earth dude did you guys see that
thing about that one meatball of humans
sitting in new york city oh yeah i got
sent that image probably 500 times so
what there's an image some guy did the
math and figured out if you were to take
all of humanity all eight billion people
squish them into one giant ball of meat
it'd be like a mile wide or a kilometer
wide and would be able to sit right in
the middle of
central park in new york city and it was
this visual of like new york city and
like this like meaty giant asteroid can
you send that to me it's no
i want to see that that sounds better
look at our subreddit it's our slash
corridor it's there about ten times i
i'm not kidding when i say that i i
literally received that from people who
follow me on social media i received it
from friends i received it from family
uh i received it internally here at
corridor and they're just like hey this
looks like what you made yeah i mean
it's an assistant because they did the
magic it came with a description of
basically what it is and it's like
that's kind of the same type of content
i do so sure are you gonna make that
video
and i'm like no they already made the
video it's one frame long yeah that's a
video it's done
true that's a yeah
stop motion with one stop i do kind of
want to see what one person's worth of
meatball looks like
one person's worth of meatballs please
one one man's meatball is another man's
is it another spaghetti
interesting okay so like how much meat
is in my friends and you just like take
your friends and you like make a
hamburger out of them
oh my god well let's see
like we can figure this out real quick
average person's like what 180 pounds
hey we're literally going over what was
in this image right now see it is a
whole video ready yeah come on
you dump the the bones and the guts
what is that what are you left with like
wouldn't the guts still count as meat to
certainly it depends it's all the guts i
mean the organs maybe
but bones are meat unless you're making
a hot dog yeah
you're going to make
but
a white tail deer is like what meat
no but in like a small a smaller
white-tailed deer you'd be able to pull
like what am i going to be crazy right
now i mean like 60 pounds texas drink
or something
sure a human maybe you guessed
california know this or no i don't know
maybe i'm way out the graphic was
basically just taking an average human
weight and multiplying it by eight
billion
taking that average density to figure
out a volume from it
uh christian's got it pulled up on his
phone right now oh and there it is hey
christian's a big meatball dude
don't send it to me
that's actually we just figured this out
i think that's the thing i think that's
why i went viral is because it's crazy
to see a giant like sphere of meat but
also
that's it that's everybody yeah wait so
that's everybody in the world that's the
idea yeah that's very small but it's
like vsauce already did that like six
years ago he put all of humanity in a
giant like pile of people in the grand
canyon
it's not novel
dang i'm all about realistic meat yield
is 58.1 pounds so yeah 60 pounds
how about a human
cannibal the meat yield of the average
human
did government watchlist for sure right
there you're good i want to see your
targeted ads after this
when factoring in muscle percentage and
average weight a typical adult human
will yield around 75 pounds of edible
meat so i was right on i said 60 and 80.
that's pretty saying that okay i'm
impressed i heard it here guys so there
you go right here we're gonna make a lot
of meatballs
or one big hamburger
one giant hamburger there's an epic
turn my friend into 80 pound
cheeseburger
dude
thank me later
i am excited about the solar panels
video i'm working on right now it's
finally actually like coming together
after three plus years of working on it
it's like i've literally started and
failed to work on this video four
separate times there's been four
separate times where i sat down and
spent a couple days researching it
writing it trying to come up with good
good hooks
cool fun facts you failed me and kind of
ended up just not really knowing how to
make it all work together
and
uh then you move on to a video and
you're like oh i'll just make a 10
million view video yeah i'm just like
all right fine fine i guess i'll move on
and make like how big are starships from
star wars
easy
this big
so what cracked the code finally um
perseverance
[Music]
uh just like
whittling away at it
as many times as i have over the last
few years i ended up coming up with
enough of a
a set of things that i was like okay a
bit of an outline is starting to form in
my head i think i know where to take
this all right i'm gonna start working
on that and so okay this is it let's
schedule it in i'm gonna work on this
video i'm gonna spend all week writing
it and i spend all week writing it and
like
it's a lot
a lot of it ends up in the end in
hindsight kind of being wasted time
because i spend like half a day
calculating all these different things
like if i wanted to make all of the
trains electric what would that require
can you have a train be completely solar
powered by just covering all the train
cars and solar and i spent half a day
running all the numbers and then at the
end of it being like
no
the end but not going to the video but i
had to do it in order to know yeah and
uh it's like jordan's submitting his
resume or his video too yeah now you
know yeah that's why we do it yeah right
and so yeah the answer was like yeah
but honestly you know
i have a few of those moments in this
video are like oh wow that is
interesting dude check that off the list
sorry um
don't check it too hard man
um don't make that check too big
back to the hospital
i came up with too many younger again
yeah let's just pretend i didn't have to
get too big uh
yeah and honestly
that has been the easy part of this
video the hard part of the video
is like trying to nail down
the direction of it and the pacing of it
and like the things to talk about versus
the things to not talk about because
essentially this video is about climate
change
with a surface entertainment factor of
like solar panels being a thing it's
kind of like the driving force of it um
and the problem with this type of
concept is that there is so much
controversy around the information that
there's like a hundred different
rebuttals to anything that i could
mention they're all like established
rebuttals that have their own debunked
uh arguments against them or
they're all debunked in them of
themselves and it's also like at what
point do i draw the line between what i
address in this video versus what i
don't like if i'm talking about battery
storage do i talk about the
environmental impact of
making lithium ion batteries
do i talk about how hard it is to you
know get all the lithium out of
argentina or the blood diamond aspect of
cobalt coming out of africa and all the
incredible amount of water usage
required to actually
get all of that stuff now i'm talking
about water now i'm talking about the
water crisis
at what point do i stop talking about
you know that or versus like all of the
pollution from making in plastics and
stuff like that and how
our oceans are going to be more there's
going to be more plastic in our oceans
than fish in like 20 years it's like
everything's connected or something yeah
it's like you're it's like humanity
lives on one planet dude and we're all
interconnected and the lives of every
person
affects the lives of many others
on a scale that we don't quite
understand
such that
our impact
and our history
is almost impossible to describe acutely
in any thing but at the same time the
attempt
to do it
and the in this decade
and
the
if you can do it concisely
you know and there's a word for this and
like conically
you know
then it's almost like
that in and of itself is worth it
dang it's beautiful yeah and it's like
you know i i could just include all of
it and go on and make a huge long video
but that's not my intent here i'm not
trying to make an informative thing i'm
trying to make entertainment
that is also educational yeah
entertainment you know it's like i'm
trying to make something that is fun
for people to watch uh and so that they
can walk away with uh the emotion of
curiosity filled
and and be like wow that was that was
just one video i learned something from
it but it was fun you could just say
look
there's a million different aspects to
this i'm just going to talk about the
things that are most relevant to
this this piece that's kind of what i'm
doing you know don't crucify me for not
addressing every goddamn thing about
this yeah
now let's go well that's like and i and
i yeah more or less that's kind of what
i do yeah um
after doing all that research
like how bad is it like how much
negative do we have to do to get
ourselves into the positive like wait
why like okay cause because like
what i'm asking is like it seems like
every single innovation in energy or
like you know power supply okay such as
batteries right there's all this like
alleged slave labor going and getting
the resources for those things because
the supply chains
aren't like i guess humanitarian right
now right so like how much negative
are we ever gonna get to a point where
on scale
we can like
have actual renewable energy without it
taking away a mass amount of resources
in another sector
like does that make sense i think so
it's like
the problem this video has is the fact
that there are too many problems that
are like crisis level problems and i'm
just trying to talk about one but like
you're saying it's like they're all kind
of interconnected so
it you know it's like
the biggest problem right now is just
the fact that like there's too many
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere we're
pumping out too many at a certain rate
that is warming up the planet at an
unsustainable rate if we keep doing this
we're literally all going to just bake
alive and so we got to stop that
and and part of that solution requires
making a huge number of lithium ion
batteries to be able to support all of
the solar panels in the world now
there's a possibility i don't know how
much of a possibility that it will
require completely decimating the
country of argentina no more malbecs for
you that's exactly what i'm talking
about though and so it's like
obviously that's not good obviously we
can't just do that however
hypothetically i'm not like actually
ragging on argentina i don't even know
if argentina has lithium i'm just saying
in general
you know maybe let's solve the more
existential crisis
first and then worry about the land
resources how we've messed up everything
just to stop the first problem and
i don't have the answers to this i don't
know if that's the right way to be right
how do we save earth
actually you know it's funny
that's towards the end of the video uh i
have it planned that basically i we get
to all this stuff and i'm like all right
so how do we save earth
and then you have my ears
and then i basically just say
i don't know yellow
you know
i pretend to end the video there and i'm
like that's a rap film crew comes in and
it's like yeah we really need to answer
that question is it really worth it and
then i we we're going to cut to this
like
doomsday news segment of like all the
stuff that's happening right now and
then i conclude the video by being like
yes
there are some things that we can do
here they are
yada yada yeah finish the video yeah no
it's uh
it's also like the consideration of of
people are not necessarily living for
the same things you know and like the
value of like what's what's valuable and
what's an efficient way to do something
and what's the the correct way to do
something is not
the same necessarily amongst even people
in the same you know place much less the
same countries or different countries
um and
so these are all factors that affect all
that and like what's important for
argentina might not be the same thing
that's in that's import as important for
chile or for the united states and
yes obviously a
a planet obviously that's like well we
all live on the planet it'd be nice to
have a planet
you know but at the same time like uh
that's i think another thing that makes
it so complicated is not only is it like
complicated to figure out
the
fundamentals
that establish the math that
you can
therefore come to like logical
scientific conclusions from but it's
also
to establish those fundamentals you also
need to be
like agreed on like hey what what is
important for us you know and sometimes
that's not always easy there's big
picture questions that are easy to
answer like every you know a healthy
earth that we can all live on right but
then it's like well
okay so
we all have
and then these guys over there started
doing something different and then now
they're doing it and it's affecting
everybody else but
now they're going off in that direction
you know somebody stopped them
it's like it brings up all these
existential questions about like
what what humans
can be doing and and how we can be doing
it too it's yeah so i'm glad you're
doing it it's my
like the more i work on this video the
more i'm starting to realize this might
be one of the most important videos i've
ever made ren podcast title ren's most
important video yet
i mean just from like
uh
very very small
yeah if you compare the two i feel like
that is probably more important yeah but
it's like also like literally as matt
and i are driving out to the desert to
uh i want to talk to you about some
legal stuff we were trespassing um hell
yeah brother um
uh i realized oh my god i never once in
this script mitch and mention like
cryptocurrencies power draw remember
back in january when i said i was going
to do this whole like cryptocurrency i
think that needs its own video
it does and
i ended up
guys don't worry ethereum's only like
one percent of the energy use of like
india okay it's not that big of a deal i
mean it's like you're saying that
jokingly but like no i'm not kind of not
far off that's why i only buy data
um and i don't know i i i feel a
responsibility to at least any time i
receive ethereum i convert it
immediately into cardona
yeah it's the main reason why i haven't
really even touched any sort of nft
stuff is because you can't without
getting a huge amount of like
misunderstood hate
just directed and i like my for my
mental health i had to step away from
all of it and just not worry about it um
and i also realized this was a hill i
didn't want to die on
so i didn't make the video so that's why
that video never happened but i feel
like i need to address that a little bit
in this and it's like
again it goes to like what do i talk
about versus what do i not talk about
well okay
hold on yeah we've gotten down into the
deepest darkest woods okay
like
first of all
what is the title of the video i i okay
it's still undecided but i'm pretty sure
the title is probably gonna be something
along the lines of vfx artist
reveals how many solar panels could
power the world maybe ideally we can
come up with a slightly shorter title
okay maybe pose it as a question again
how many solar panels can power the
world the point the point of it
is to eventually reveal how many solar
panels would be required to power the
world now obviously you need to have
parameters to get to that point
but like
if the
if that's the point of the video then
you know
where you can come back around to
yeah you know to cut off a tangent and i
feel like
any time you're doing anything
like nick and i were filming a video
today and it's like oh well where where
do we start is it like
is it like
this is like you're writing a history
essay and you need to it's like well i'm
writing a history essay
how far back do i go yeah
like
i want to do something on the
revolutionary war okay do i go back to
like
seven do i go to the mayflower do i go
to like the expansion of the british
empire in the 17th century do i like
where do i start
or do i just start with like this that
makes me feel silly do i start with
lexington and just go go i mean start
with the title like you did basically
yeah and and to be fair i feel like i'm
voicing
complaints that i've already overcome
like i already have a theme of the video
i already have a main idea
you know like inception if you can boil
down the idea to like one i one thing
that they can take away i think i've got
that cool and and yeah it basically
comes down to like
we got to make everything electric
yeah i'm this is a video
advertising electricity
not not
not solar not renewable energy like
literally just like the concept of
electricity is awesome it's the hi i
literally make a drug reference to it
like yo you got that dude it is like you
kind of like look around sketchy and
then like you pull up like a little like
how are you storing your electricity
that's the question is how you store
that dog yeah how are you storing it
yeah there's there's a lot of like cool
like little fun facts in this video that
i think will blow people's minds i'm
trying to go full off grid in texas dude
are you i mean not like some of that
soon but within the next five years
i'm trying to i'm facing to go full
off-grid dude that'd be awesome i
wouldn't go you'll never find me dude
it's it's super doable you just need uh
you need a energy source and an energy
you need a backup generator about a
thousand pounds a thousand gallons of
propane okay you need some solar panels
you need some battery storage and well
windmills
that's about it windmills
that's pretty much about it then i told
you about how uh i when i discovered you
had a stream on your property that you
can literally install like uh
it doesn't run full time yeah but i
could still use it when you can use it
when it's running like i've literally
watched so many videos of dudes
converting washing machines into diy
hydroelectric generators so many videos
how many videos and
i don't know dozens i feel like you
watch one and you're like oh okay
i get it i i i go down rabbit holes
through the planet dude i end up on the
other side being like why am i here
um
and why don't i have a washing machine
because it's like this guy's like oh my
my electricity source broke down i gotta
go fix it i haven't touched it in three
years he's just had this washing machine
that's got plants grown over it that uh
he had to like rewire it so that can get
energy out of it and you just got all
you need is basically just a water
source that's slightly higher elevation
than where the energy thing is you put
it into a hose and it goes shooting out
into this thing that spins
a little disc and then it generates
electricity
and you can have like a few of them next
to each other with a few different tubes
going to it and that's enough
electricity to power your house
all day like 24 7 for three straight
years until like a bearing breaks and
it's like i guess i'll go fix it that's
the best part about youtube is watching
dudes who don't care about youtube at
all turning old stuff into new stuff
it's the best man yeah i go down such
rabbit holes too on that stuff that was
the the draw of like prim tech you know
like it's just this dude like making
huts and stuff without really saying
anything and
yeah you guys what's that
satisfying yeah there's that freaking uh
smelting videos diy
jake is that your goal is to go
completely off grid uh
i would say that it's
if if there is a way to do it that is
consistent
and
like
accessible for me yeah i would do that
it's it's totally doable so what i've
here's my this is my like
far-fetched plan i'm gonna give you my
far-fetched tenure
ten year or ten years ten years okay
like ten so
you do
maybe you stay on the city grid just
because why not when they're they are
producing electricity but you certainly
want storage
and you want backup power so you can get
backup power they have these home backup
generators you can hook one of those up
they run on propane they're only running
when your power goes out so it's not
like you're like burning propane all the
time
um so there's that that's a good that's
a good like immediate option for when
your power goes out but then you can
also keep they also make these huge home
batteries now and you don't necessarily
need to have them plugged into solar
panels if you're plugged into city power
you can plug the panels you can plug
these giant home battery systems into
your house you can have a bunch of them
because they all you can chain them up
and
they can charge up from city power and
anytime they go out you can use those
too
or if you have solar panels you can you
can charge directly into them
so you can have basically you have a
balance of like three power sources city
solar and backup generation you just
covered 100 yeah and then and then and
then for food you can do um
if you keep like a couple cows on your
property
like you have enough food my one bedroom
in in la just a cow in the back well i
live in texas
yeah do it no more cows guys do you know
how much
white tails dedicated to cows fine
white-tailed deer access deals that
doesn't what doesn't matter
a couple hogs like
that's actually more accessible groups
hogs i feel like a couple hogs in the
back because then you feed them all your
scraps and like
yeah they can be wild hogs too
wild hogs will tear stuff down
too either because like peasants and
like the medieval times would like sleep
above their livestock because the heat
would rise up and warm them up
i'm not going to do that you're going to
say cuddle with the hogs which i thought
that was going that direction you think
i'm doing it anyway so ren i already
have the land this is straight hog heat
there's wild grasses you could have
cattle graze it it's not taking up any
more land for cows it's like and they're
really good eating and they're not
they're docile no i hear you that's that
yeah
sorry i just like or you could do
white-tailed deer you could do access
whatever but either way you have a
little herd of whatever this livestock
is and anytime you need one you just
walk out there with the old rifle
take one
harvest it and you have meat and you put
it in your fridge what do you mean dear
god and it's you know where it comes
from it's green
i don't have any fundamental problem
with that it's just and now you and now
it's like okay and then you just get a
couple chickens you do a little garden i
do want chickens for sure dude fresh
eggs
how would you like how would you like to
know the name of the chicken that you
got your egg from son
i want to know the name of the egg dude
i don't don't stop at the chicken little
vegetable garden
and then
and what else do you need no i mean for
the record
for the record i support all of what you
just said on on on a on a personal scale
all of that is totally fine i'm just
saying cows in general are a huge part
of the climate problem
they keep farting yes yeah
no like methane is literally like 180
times more
uh heat capturable that's that's a word
now um than carbon dioxide okay fine
i'll do axis deer no
you should do a video on how much cow
farts there are i mean can you reduce
the color the difference is that it's
better methane sticks around the
atmosphere far less it's got like a life
cycle of like chicken parts
can you give them like antacids or
something
like on a large scale to help reduce
how much land as a percentage of the
total lower 48 states of america so not
including alaska or hawaii what
percentage of that land is dedicated to
cows
i think i could probably guess i'm gonna
guess okay
it's
real okay what do you guys think i'm
gonna just read it and go last and just
leverage okay so i'm gonna say 43
43 yes it's a high number it's a super
high number but i'm starting there
okay yeah i'm gonna go with a modest 23
okay
i think it's i think it's probably above
50 but under 60.
all right this didn't go the way i
thought um nick was by far the closest
it's 41
well
i thought you guys were gonna guess like
three percent five percent do you mean
like privately owned ranch land grazing
land and the land used to grow food just
for cats oh my god dude that's a lot
that's a lot
i was shooting for the stars there yeah
no it's i'm not even kidding about half
of the entire country the land is 100
allocated only for the use of cows
for feeding them keeping them yeah and
killing them wow yeah
and then if you count the mcdonald's
eating them as well yeah
it's just it's just the grazing land so
like you know let's say you have a farm
with cows you got a whole bunch of land
they're allowed to go over all that land
that's land that's reserved for the cows
you're not really doing much else with
that land maybe you have like some stuff
going up but for the most part it's for
the cows
nobody else is doing much with that land
either i might okay well we could solar
panel chickens we could well okay so
what what could you do with it i don't
know you could play it you could have a
lot of traffic
because you could come up with a free
market way to incentivize people to use
their land differently oh absolutely
that's the beauty of capitalism is that
you could just say hey you could get
paid more to do this with your land and
somebody'd be like really
and they'd shoot all the cows and eat
them
yeah cut to south park yeah
that episode for me and then it'll be
one wheel solar farms no for me i i have
less of a problem with the land reserved
for cows than i do with the land
reserved to grow corn that is used to
make ethanol yeah there's a tremendous
amount of land just to grow the corn for
ethanol which is just the government
subsidize that weren't they like ethanol
is better well okay no that's the thing
ethanol i heard that yeah what i'm
saying is that that is a product that
goes into gasoline
yeah uh it makes gasoline better um
but like if we don't need any gasoline
if
we got rid of all gasoline cars suddenly
we don't need to grow all of that
ethanol and we could just put solar
panels over all the land that we use to
grow all of those plants for the ethanol
yeah and that's more than enough land to
have all of the solar panels you'd need
to power the entire country now that's
on the same page on that like i'm always
saying whenever we have this
conversation i'm going yeah man you talk
about government subsidies that's what
the government should use their
subsidies on incentivize people to
develop a new economy so that that you
can so you can get rid of gasoline cars
but do it in a way that people are
financially incentivized to do so not
mandated with the bludgeoning tool of
like don't you can't buy a car anymore
that's elec or that's gas like
give me a reason why is it better is it
better is it more affordable like
because you're not getting them on like
hey it's just better for the environment
because at the end of the day you see
how people act when it comes to like
you know the the like even like the
stimulus checks and stuff and like
whether people can save five dollars on
a 30 item whether they buy it from china
or buy it from america people don't make
they make that decision just based on
i'm gonna save the five bucks i'm gonna
buy the cheaper car gasoline's cheap
right now i don't care that's what i
gotta do and look
that is the real deal for most people
every day because a lot most people it's
you know you don't have the cash you
don't have the time you don't have you
don't want the headache i get it but
like you talk about where to put money
where to put tax money i mean i wasn't
but yeah okay no well okay well i am no
i mean like that's a whole other topic
do i like that i was struggling with do
i talk about like how do we address this
from an economic standpoint do we
implement a carbon tax or carbon cap or
cap and trade i think uh they're yeah
i'm not really gonna touch them i just
feel like if the goal is like hey yo we
need to get rid of gasoline cars and
probably a few other things the most
powerful thing is is the correct market
incentive exactly that's what i'm
getting yeah like if if you have the
correct market incentive then it's just
going to happen and a lot of people
think carbon tax is the right way to go
some people don't um i'm not enough of
an economics expert to know what the
right way is but at the same time i also
don't think
these even with the correct type of
market incentives i don't think that's
going to move fast enough
i don't know man i mean i think we
actually legitimately do have to have
some mandates to get this thing going or
we will literally all die
i'm not kidding the climate outlook if
we do not stop this stuff is extremely
dire i know and i've
again it's like
yes i i know what you're saying but if
it starts to become that dire
then that also speeds up the change of
the the pace of change yeah at which
people act and ultimately that's why
they're sort of correlated you know but
is there a point where like it goes over
and it's too late to change it yeah uh
cascading events i think are what
they're called is like
at a certain point like you know if it
starts warming up too much suddenly all
the permafrost in russia is starting to
melt releasing all of the methane right
which is now accelerating the heat even
further
you know the mandates you have to make
are even more intrusive into liberties
at that point and people are going to be
less likely to take them
so i feel like but you want to introduce
it gradually sooner it's not like your
mandates are going to be functional at
that point
they're going to be laughable at that
point
you know it's like oh yeah you're the
federation of russia is going to tell
somebody in siberia what to do they're
going to come out there and they're
going to have a government agent whose
family is back in moscow dying from the
same [ __ ] like that's not going to
you
you need to focus on like what people's
spending habits are now
and how people can spend their money in
a way and live their lives in a way that
that actually
is is effective at
doing this type of stuff the sad reality
is that we
and likely most of the people watching
this podcast aren't going to be that
affected by this they'll be affected in
small ways but the real victims of this
are going to be all of the people in
india in in africa who don't have the
resources to handle a week-long 150
degree heat wave right where literally
dozens of millions of people will die
over the course of a few days it's like
that's a very realistic possibility in
the very near future yeah i've been
reading this book called the ministry of
the future it's kind of it's a it's a
bit of a
a take on what the next you know however
many years are going to look like
in fiction
uh from a client stan a climate
standpoint uh and that was one of the
things there's a massive heat wave that
killed 20 million people in india in a
day yeah in the book in the book yeah
and and it's like yeah no i don't
disagree like those we've seen those
types of events increasing and i think
it's very hard for people it's very hard
to deny the acuteness with which it's
at least having lived in los angeles and
seeing the amount of like output of
human
trash
that we put into the world it's like
yeah
and then you fly and then you realize i
can fly around the world
in a day
on a plane
it's not that big right
so like
you know i i get it there's like
controversy around it but at the end of
the day man it's just about hey what can
you do to reduce it on your side the way
that you live your life maybe you spend
that extra five bucks to buy something
that's like made in america because you
know that at least when it was
manufactured it was done
probably in a more efficient manner yeah
you're touching on another thing it's
like the whole idea of personal
responsibility in this matter was
literally started by the fossil fuel
industries funding propaganda
and and the whole idea of recycling to
kind of like shift the blame from them
on to us as consumers we have to step up
individually otherwise shame on you
you know meanwhile like yeah seventy
percent of all of the greenhouse gas
emissions are being made by the top 100
companies
you're not getting your ford f-150 and
drive down to the recycling plant every
weekend yeah piece of crap i guess what
i'm saying is that like the real
solution
the water
the water thing where it's like what 30
percent of water usage in california use
is used residential and 70 is
agricultural
right
i'm gonna take a shower that's shorter
yeah yeah like any sort of water waste
that you will do by taking a long shower
is like
it's not that big of a deal it's it's
like so
irrelevant
but like maybe don't have four acres of
grass
that you're watering to be pristinely
green grass is one of the biggest
wasters of yeah of water dude you know
that's a whole other thing california's
water crisis is becoming real very
quickly that that the
i had this whole there's when i got this
house that i have there was like this
whole area that the guy was keeping
before i owned it that was just keeping
as like trimmed
watered grass
in the middle of texas hill country and
it's like
this isn't supposed to look like this
this is supposed to look like natural
grasslands with like different levels of
flora and fauna and like tree diversity
so that birds and like snakes and foxes
and like this life can live here why are
you fighting against that it wants to do
that just let it
let it do that and it will
it will do that right and it's like
people are like no i want i want my
saint augustine three inch grass
as far as i can see
why
i mean you know it's
there's a disconnect between what people
are a little bit sure
and what is perhaps morally right and at
the end of the day if you can just do it
who cares right
no no i mean i agree i know i know i'm
just saying
i'm putting mine
in their shoes in that right right right
yeah because this is what i'm going back
to about like the spending habits it's
like people you only you save a penny
because it's jumbo size man you know
yeah i mean the yeah the solutions here
have to be very very large scale i mean
we all have to contribute obviously but
it's like
i don't it's this has all been very very
complex and and a lot to wrangle in my
head so uh yeah so let us know in the
comments how badly we are wrong about
this
so okay to at least leave this in a
slightly more optimistic note i know i
was saying we will literally all die by
the end of the century which is it by
the end of the century oh yeah no it's
on current on some on
current projections that's true yes what
jake said so the reason why i'm
optimistic is because
uh
humans are very good at adapting and
we're very good at problem solving and
coming up with solutions to hard
problems
and at a certain what what's required
right now is for everyone to be on the
same page with their regard to the
importance of this problem yeah right
now there's too many people who don't
really care enough
too many politicians who don't
understand it at all
who are making decisions that they
have no right to be making you make it
um you know and it's like
yeah
yeah and
it's just okay i think we will we will
be fine
we will be fine humanity will be fine
but unfortunately like everything humans
do
we never get on the same page and we can
never agree to anything until people
start dying people will have to start
dying by the millions before and then
what's happening oh [ __ ] that's the
unfortunate we actually have to do this
because if we don't everyone's gonna die
and then all of a sudden everybody every
duck gets in the row it's when the rich
people start getting affected then
they're like oh oh yeah oh yeah i was
the first one to say climbing
yeah i know totally i know you know it's
funny unfortunately that is the way that
it works in that book that i mentioned
uh the ministry of the future uh
it was very poignant they they mentioned
how uh those heat waves were like
millions of people would just die in a
day started becoming so frequent
uh people compared it to school
shootings in america at how like uh oh
yeah another million people died like
everyone's like really upset about it
today but in a few days they will forget
about it and i was just like
yeah yeah that's scary thought man
whoa
oh well on that note yeah we should wrap
this up this episode of hardcore history
you guys want to get something to eat
yeah
jordan just came on here to get
something to eat man
you're out here talking about we did
tell them there would be dinner yeah
where's the appetizers sorry man where's
the human meat well that was a good long
one i was like yeah i didn't expect to
start really diving into some of those
like climate issues there uh i hope that
was interesting and enlightening for
some of you if you have any feedback on
any of that leave a comment down below
please don't curse like we're not
experts okay we're youtubers we're
trying to do our best with the tools
that we have available please just try
to understand that and
don't you know if you have something
constructive to say maybe focus on that
i mean also if anyone has small ways to
like i guess reduce your energy
footprint any tips or tricks leave them
in a comment yeah yeah because i'm
always open to stuff that's actually
like
possible to do you know
i can't keep chickens or hogs
right now come on over yeah sometimes
trying to reduce your personal energy
footprint
isn't really
it doesn't matter that much yeah but
nick if you do have the chickens then
when [ __ ] really hits the fan then you
can eat the chickens man granted you
know what will actually make a huge
difference and i it's super
lame to have to say it but it's like
getting an electric car
is actually a tangible huge i got told
off the other day because i'm like dude
i really think it's great that tesla's
you seem everywhere right now and
they're like
yeah well they uh support child slavery
so and i'm like what child slavery yeah
like something like that oh are they
talking about the cobalt thing yes okay
that's another thing tesla has actually
figured out how to remove cobalt from
their lithium-ion batteries so their
next format the 4680 battery cells
aren't going to have any cobalt in them
let me just put that in my pocket
most of the content of a battery a
lithium-ion battery is nickel and carbon
there's two percent lithium in it so
there's not actually that's somebody
writing it off in their head
to be like yeah you know i don't want to
think about this yeah well i know but
that's unfortunately you just have to go
well
i'm gonna get one or i'm gonna do it
anyways the perfect response to child
slavery well yeah i'm gonna do it anyway
[Laughter]
i mean in a non like
significant context like what what are
you supposed to say to that it's yeah
it's yeah it's it's it's tough um you
don't even need to get a tesla tesla's
very expensive that's the main problem
right now i think anyone who's ever been
in an electric car would love to have an
electric car the problem is that they're
expensive but they're coming down in
price every year my first electric car
was a used 2011 nissan leaf it was that
little blue piece of crap it had a 45
mile range because it had such a crappy
old battery it's supposed to be like 85
90 miles it did not come close to that
and
yeah that was
it was i loved it it was a great car
do that buy a used electric car
it will be so much better for the
environment than pretty much any
other specific thing you can do with
your energy footprint in your house
i mean obviously you can like fly less
that would make a big difference but
well this is
[Music]
they said if you don't take that shorter
shower boy and buy that renewable glass
water bottle
it's your fault
well they drink up all the oil
[Music]
and we sat there and we toiled
oh my god we have been doing this
podcast for so long today this is a long
one we really got into it all right
thanks for listening everybody either
sorry or you're welcome we do it all the
time here on quarter cast you don't know
what we're gonna do
we didn't even talk about my car
accident
three two one